l'intérêt précoce pour ce domaine est né
de ma fascination pour les sciences et
les mathématiques
cependant au moment d'étudier la
géométrie mon intérêt portait davantage
sur la manière dont les preuves étaient
découvertes que sur les théorèmes eux
mêmes
de même en sciences l'intérêt concerner
davantage la manière dont les choses
étaient découvertes que les contenus de
ces découvertes love story n'était pas
aussi excitant plus de lois qui le pont
dès ce merveilleux paragraphe est une
citation de ré solomonoff l'un des plus
grands héros du bandiat nisme si pierre
simon laplace la place est certainement
le père du belize yanis mme david hume
on est probablement le grand-père et ré
solomonoff on est clairement l'enfant
prodige
dans une série d'articles ses talents de
1960 à sa mort en 2009 solomonov aura
sans doute combiné de la manière la plus
parfaite qu'ils soient les inspirations
géniales mais incomplète de ses
illustres prédécesseurs
la théorie de l'induction ainsi conçu
par solomonoff mélangea à merveille les
deux grands piliers du savoir intuit et
par qm discutée par la place exploité
par turing est formalisé par comme golf
à savoir la théorie des probabilités et
la théorie du calcul
la théorie de la probabilité
algorithmique qui en résulte est qu'on
appelle désormais l'induction de solomon
of permis de cerner avec une clarté
étonnante ce qui était possible et ce
qui ne l'était pas il y a très peu de
lecture qui m'auront fait trembler avec
autant d'émotion de questionnement et
d'émerveillement que les écrits
somptueux du sol nov
c'est comme si devant mes yeux je voyais
ce combiné délicatement et parfaitement
les merveilleuses pièces d'un saint
graal dont j'avais été sur la trace
depuis de longues années alors que je me
noyais temps de sombres lecture en
épistémologie et en théorie du machine
learning lire solomonoff est très
nettement le plus grand bouleversement
épistémique j'ai connu et très
probablement que j'aurai connu dans ma
vie
c'est avec énormément de joie et
enthousiasme que je vais essayer de vous
expliquer l'argument le plus important
en faveur de la validité épistémique de
l'induction de seulement neuf et qui me
semble être aussi du coup l'argument
théorique le plus convaincant en faveur
du bail à nice même si ben y en a
d'autres comme le théorème
d'admissibilité détails quotidiens les
termes de la casse complète des
algorithmes bizien le théorème du livre
de contes néerlandais et le théorème de
james cox parmi d'autres temps cet
argument quasi décisif en faveur du bail
à nice mme est le théorème
d'incomplétude de ce long monologue et
avant de vous le présenter je vous
invite à lire ce que seul au monop
disait à son sujet dans un article
intitulé la probabilité algorithmique
résout tél le problème de l'induction
il devrait être noté que le seul
argument qu'il faut considérer pour
l'utilisation de cette technique pour
l'induction et leur efficacité pour
obtenir de bonnes prédictions
probabiliste pour les événements futurs
le fait que les propriétés de ces
techniques sont en accord ou non avec
nos intuitions sur l'induction est une
considération secondaire principale
question est est ce que ça marche comme
nous allons le voir
oui ça marche aujourd'hui on va voir ce
qui a justifié seul mot 9 à conclure que
oui ça marche et on verra la prochaine
fois comment selon mena a aussi démontré
l'impossibilité de faire en sorte que
quelque chose marche vraiment en
pratique hashtag teaser pour
s'émerveiller au théorème mathématique
mais aussi et surtout pour toutes la
construction préalable d'une théorie
d'une pureté délicieuse je tiens à
exprimer toute ma gratitude et toute mon
admiration
merci rei merci monsieur selon renault
alors avant
nov considérait être l'argument ultime
pour montrer que l'induction de seomoz
nov
ça marche je vais rapidement rappeler en
quoi consiste cette induction comme on
l'a vu dans les deux dernières vidéos de
la série 7 induction de solomonoff
repose sur cinq fondement 1 les données
sont numérisées de toute théorie doit
parier sur tout donné observable 3 toute
théorie doit être calculable 4 les
théories plus complexes sont
exponentiellement moins crédible a
priori ce qu'on appelle aussi du rasoir
d'occam et 5 toute prédiction doit se
conformer aux lois des probabilités en
particulier une fois la priory défini il
s'agit tout bêtement d'appliquer les
lois de probabilité pour calculer les
crédences a posteriori des théories t
sachant les données collectées des haies
pour prédire les probabilités des
données x observable mais non encore
observés via d'un côté la formule de
pays et via de l'autre la loi des
probabilités total si ce que je viens de
dire ne coule pas bien dans votre
cerveau je vous invite à voir et à
revoir
les deux épisodes précédents et celui
sur la formule du savoir
mais alors que 10e
le théorème d'incomplétude de solomonoff
pour le comprendre on va supposer que à
chaque instant l'univers exécute un
algorithme possiblement randomisée et
nous révèle ensuite un bit d'information
0 hu et à chaque instant avant de
recevoir le prochain bits
nous allons exécuter et rigoureusement
les calculs de l'induction de solomonoff
ce qui va nous amener à assigner une
probabilité sur la valeur du prochain
bits d'information qu'on observera noter
que le formalisme et ici équivalent à
celui de l'épisode 32 à la légère
différence près que le choix du prochain
bits peut être randomisés ce qu'on va
faire maintenant c'est comparer le pari
de l'induction de solomonoff à la
meilleure prédiction possible qu'on
aurait pu faire si on connaissait les
lois de l'univers
mais si on ne connaissait pas le
résultat de la randomisation exploité
par l'univers une autre probabilité
n'est pas cette meilleure prédiction
possible
alors on va perdre des points et plus
notre probabilité est loin de la
meilleure prédiction possible plus on va
perdre des points
typiquement on peut considérer que le
nombre de points perdus est égal au
carré de la différence entre la
meilleure prédiction possible et la
prédiction de l'induction de solomon of
la question posée par seul mot 9 est
ensuite la suivante combien de points
perdre à ton en moyenne quelle est
l'espérance du nombre de points perdus
et bien de façon stupéfiante sur le mall
of a démontré que l'induction de
solomonoff garantie de perdre assez peu
de points et que d'une certaine manière
c'est aussi la seule manière d'y arriver
reviendra sur ce second aspect la
prochaine fois expliquons d'abord ce que
ça signifie que de perdre peu de points
eh bien le théorème d'incomplétude de
seulement neuf garantie que l'espérance
de la perte totale de points après une
infinité de paris est au plus la
complexité de solomonoff que
l'algorithme randomisés exploiter
l'univers pour calculer le prochain bits
d'information à nous envoyer incroyable
avec l'induction de seulement neuf
garantie en gros que après un certain
nombre d'erreurs ou non commettra
essentiellement plus aucune et surtout
ceci est valable quel que soit univers
considéré pourvu qu'il obéit à une thèse
de turkish turing avec possiblement une
randomisation c'est en ce sens que
l'induction de solomonoff peut être
qualifié de complète elle permet
d'apprendre rapidement les bonnes lois
dans tout univers calculable pas
opposition
les autres méthodes seront quasi
assurément incomplète dans le sens où
pour certains unis
heures leur total d'erreur divergeraient
vers l'infini elle commettront une
infinité d'erreurs dont certains univers
une dernière chose à noter c'est que
l'incomplétude de solomonoff englobe
bien évidemment le cas d'un univers
déterministe où chaque nouveau beat est
calculé selon des lois fixe et
prédéterminés dans ce cas aussi
l'induction de somme 9 finira par mettre
des probabilités arbitrairement proches
que 1 à la valeur des prochains bit que
l'univers révélera bref la complétude
tout seul mot nov
c'est un résultat ultra bas laisse plus
que toute autre chose
c'est le théorème qui m'a fait conclure
à 99 999 % que le bail à nice mme l
épistémologie multi
mais d'où vient ce miracle de solomonoff
alors ça va se corser un petit peu mais
j'ai quand même envie de vous expliquer
une démonstration de ce bijou de baïse à
nice mme même si bon on va pas entrer
dans tous les détails non plus l'idée de
la démonstration que je vous propose
s'appuie sur le curseur de turing dont
on a parlé dans l'épisode 14
souvenez-vous ce curseur est placé sur
une droite graduée avec tout à droite
une priorité et tout à gauche nos
théories alternatives à si le curseur
est au milieu ça veut dire qu'ils jugent
les deux théories aussi crédible l'une
que l'autre et plus ils penchent à
droite plus il juge que la théorie t est
plus crédible que la théorie à on va
maintenant considérée à droite la vraie
théorie tes étoiles qui régit les
données observées les normes astuce va
maintenant être de remplacer la théorie
à à gauche par n'importe quelle théorie
y compris la théorie tes étoiles
formellement ça correspond à l'union de
toutes les théories ou encore à tes
étoiles ou non telle étoile et
intuitivement la théorie à gauche est
autre que l'induction de solomonoff
alors quel est l'intérêt de faire cela
et bien pour commencer on peut calculer
la position initiale du curseur de
turing rapide calcul montre que cette
position initiale
et forcément le log de la probabilité a
priori de tes étoiles
si on considère la priory de solomon off
on a vu que cette probabilité a priori
est au moins deux puissances - la
complexité de solomonoff de la vraie
théorie tes étoiles
encore une fois je vous renvoie vers les
épisodes précédents pour comprendre ce
que cela signifie
du coup en considérant le logarithme
compass 2 ont conclu que la position
initiale du curseur de turing est à
droite deux mois deux cas de tes étoiles
mais par ailleurs on sait que la théorie
des étoiles ou non des étoiles est
forcément plus crédible que juste tes
étoiles
encore une fois rapide calcul permet de
le vérifier formellement mais alors ça
veut dire que quoi qu'il arrive on sera
forcément toujours à gauche du zéro on
pensera toujours forcément du côté des
étoiles ou non étoiles bref on commença
à droite de moins de cas de tes étoiles
et on reste forcément à gauche 2 0
ça veut dire que le curseur de turing ne
pourra pas trop se déplacer vers la
droite ou dit plus formellement la somme
des déplacement du curseur de turing
vers la droite sera forcément au plus de
cas de tes étoiles
or chaque erreur de prédiction de
l'induction de selommes nov
vis-à-vis de thé étoile correspond
nécessairement un mouvement du curseur
en effet s'il a un diction de somone of
fait la même prédiction que tes étoiles
au sujet d'une donnée d'été à l'instant
t
sachant les données passées des
intérieurs ap alors quelle que soit la
valeur de la donne et d'été elle sera
tout aussi surprenante sachant
l'induction de solomonoff que ça
chantait l'étoile dès lors le rapport de
surprise sera égal à 1 donc son nougat
rythme sera égal à zéro ce qui revient à
dire que le curseur ne se déplacera pas
en fait
l'ampleur du déplacement du curseur
notamment vers la droite est une mesure
de l'erreur de prédiction de l'induction
de soul dont 9 par rapport à la
prédiction via tes étoiles pour les
matheux parmi vous ou pour ceux qui ont
vu mon live sur la théorie de
l'information
l'espérance de l'ampleur du déplacement
du curseur n'est autre que la divergence
de koulouba kleiber entre la vraie
théorie tes étoiles et l'induction de
solomonoff et comme cette divergence de
cuba kleiber est supérieur ou égal à
zéro en espérance le curseur se
déplacera toujours vers la droite mais
alors l'espérance de la somme de tous
les déplacements et forcément borné par
le déplacement maximale total vers la
droite qui comme on l'a vu est égale à
la complexité de solomon de la vraie
théorie
or pour une prédiction sur un beat on
peut montrer que l'erreur quadratique de
prédiction est inférieure à une
constante fois cette divergence qu'à
elle ainsi l'espérance de la somme des
erreurs de prédiction est opus une
constante fois l'espérance de la somme
des déplacements qui est haut plus
l'espace de déplacement entre - 2 cas de
tes étoiles et 0
qui est égal à oka de tes étoiles
sécurité on vient de démontrer que la
somme des erreurs de prédiction de
l'induction de solomonoff est au plus de
allen dodo divisé par deux fois la
complexité de ces hormones of de lavera
théorique étoiles et comme elle n 2 2
ghz et par 2 est inférieur à 1
on peut l'oublier et notez que cette
magie de solomonoff réside dans les
propriétés du curseur de turing qui sont
elles mêmes des conséquences des lois
des probabilités conditionnelles
bref si ça marche c'est en fait vraiment
grâce à la loi de pays et donc à la
formule du savoir
on peut remarquer une implication
rassurantes de ses théorèmes comme
annoncé à la dernière fois le choix du
langage joue assez peu en effet en
définition l'induction de somme 9 dans
le langage m
au lieu du langage l on aurait une
quantité d'erreurs égal à la complexité
de ses homologues de la théorie tes
étoiles dans le langage m
ce qui est aupuce la complexité de ce
mode offre de télé toile dans le langage
elle plus la longueur du compilateur
voilà qui rajoute une quantité en fait
assez négligeable surtout pour des
univers de complexité supérieur au
mégaoctet ce qui semble être largement
le cas de notre univers alors j'ajoute
que sur le mode off lui s'est
particulièrement intéressé à des langage
binaire dix ans près fixes qui sont très
liés à la consente à mega de chat in
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 29
cependant le théorème d'incomplétude du
solomonoff exprimé avec la divergence
qu'à elle et lui tout à fait général et
s'applique bien au delà des langage
binaire son préfixe en fait ce théorème
est entièrement un théorème des
probabilités
dans la mesure où en considérant à
droite le logarithme de 1 / la
probabilité a priori de la vraie théorie
le théorème d'incomplétude pesant fait
s'exprimer sans aucune référence à la
calculabilité exigé par seul mot nov
ainsi pourvu qu'on applique le bat izan
isme avec un a priori universel c'est à
dire un a priori qui assigne créé dans
strictement positive à tout et aux rites
et l'ensemble des rondes dénombrable de
théorie et pourvu que les données sont
effectivement générés pour une théorie t
de l'ensemble des théories qu'on a
considéré le théorème d'incomplétude
s'applique en exécutant les calculs
bayésiens on commet une somme cumulée
fini d'erreurs malgré le fait d'avoir à
effectuer une infinité de paris et ça
c'est quand même ultra ultra officines
en particulier sa montre que la
complétude peut persister même pour une
induction calculable pourvu que
l'ensemble des théories considérer est
récurent sivement inhumé râble est ce
que je vous dis ne vous parle pas ne
vous inquiétez pas on en reparlera la
prochaine fois et puis bon c'est pas si
important que cela
avant de conclure je vais me permettre
de revenir à la citation de sauver neuf
que j'ai donné en début de vidéo
il devrait être noté que le seul
argument qu'il faut considérer pour
l'utilisation de ces techniques pour
l'induction et leur efficacité pour
obtenir de bonnes prédictions
probabiliste pour les événements futurs
le fait que les propriétés de ces
techniques sont en accord ou non avec
nos intuitions sur l'induction est une
considération secondaire
la principale question est est ce que ça
marche comme nous allons le voir
oui ça marche cette isation est vraiment
fascinant
elle réagit certainement à beaucoup de
critiques de l'induction de solomonoff
qui selon somme 9 frappe à côté de la
cible
en effet bien souvent dans beaucoup de
livres d'épistémologie notamment on
donne énormément d'importance à nos
intuitions sur l'induction typiquement
on va souvent vouloir formaliser des
notions comme la vérité l'objectivité la
causalité l'intelligence la conscience
vous voir encore la compréhension des
choses
ainsi beaucoup de scientifiques
affirment que les algorithmes donc pas
d'intelligence car ils n'ont pas une
compréhension des opérations sémantique
qui sont censés effectuer
c'est notamment le cas lorsqu'on insiste
sur l'expérience de pensée de la chambre
chinoise qui est censée montrer que les
algorithmes ne font que de la
manipulation de symboles et qu'il ne
pense pas finalement la découverte la
plus stupéfiante de seulement 9
c'est peut-être surtout la découverte de
l'inutilité de tous ces concepts pour
résoudre le problème de l'induction
même si la notion de vrais théorie nous
a par ailleurs été utile pour montrer
l'efficacité de l'induction de celle aux
menottes
de façon intéressante elle pas été
utiles pour définir cette induction en
tout cas s'il s'agit de faire des
prédictions ou s'il s'agit de prendre
les décisions pour augmenter la
probabilité d'un futur meilleur
toutes ces notions que notre intuition
juge instinctivement si incontournable
ne sont en fait pas ou du moins selon
mena faire montrer qu'il est largement
possible de faire sens et c'est
finalement ça le grand paris dubai zanis
comme je l'avais annoncé au début de
cette série le bannissement peut être vu
comme le fait de faire du langage des
probabilités
le langage du savoir bon si on suit les
pas de seulement 9
il reste nécessaire de compléter ce
langage
par le langage de la calculabilité
néanmoins si on en croit ces logos nov
ces deux langages semble à la fois
nécessaire mais aussi suffisant à
l'instar du gros livre de wittgenstein
dont le langage est incapable de parler
d'éthique le livre complet sur
l'induction un cri par solomonoff ne
permet de parler de rien d'autre que de
probabilités de calcul de données
et ça c'est de loin le plus grand
bouleversement est le plus grand vertige
philosophique que le bail zanis m'assume
offrir à en croire seulement 9 pour
savoir il n'y aura finalement besoin de
rien d'autre de plus que de probabilités
de calcul et de données